[Music]
on this Thursday night navigating new
variants the polarizing perspectives on
keeping covid-19 at Bay this was a
prudent thing to do as demand for cold
medications outpaces Supply at some
Canadian pharmacies as you can see right
now most of my shelf is bare the
speaker's stalemate in the U.S and how
it's paralyzing government
a Royal Rumble Prince Harry's stunning
claim his brother attacked him
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Sophie Louie good
evening and thanks for joining us new
coronavirus testing is now a reality for
thousands of Travelers Bound for Canada
starting today travelers from China Hong
Kong and Macau must provide proof of a
negative covid-19 test prior to
departure the federal government says
the temporary requirement will be in
place for at least 30 Days by no means
is Canada alone on new rules for travel
from China several European nations
Japan Australia and the United States
have imposed similar or in some cases
more severe restrictions but with
growing concern over the new sub-variant
that's rapidly overtaking cases in the
U.S some are questioning whether
ottawa's focus on China is The Right
Move Mackenzie gray has our top story
tonight
Travelers arriving from Hong Kong are
reluctantly accepting the new covid
requirements the numbers
um look pretty high over there so I
guess they're just being cautious I
think it's a good idea because like it's
helped to safeguard out the country but
experts say the new rules forcing
passengers from China Hong Kong and
Macau to have a negative test will do
little to stop any potential new
variants the goal is to keep specific
variants from being imported to Canada
we know that those very focused travel
measures aren't going to do that the
transport Minister defending the federal
government's decision keeping in mind by
the way the pressure that our public
health system is dealing with right now
this was a prudent thing to do from
Beijing condemnation for Western
countries who have implemented the very
same requirements China puts on incoming
international travels
they also said covet in China was under
control
but scenes from Chinese hospitals tell a
different story with lingering vaccine
hesitancy and limited immunity from
earlier infections abandoning the
previous covet zero policy has left
Chinese hospitals or
this doctor admitting his Hospital in
Eastern China is short staffed
with an estimated million cases a day
experts are worried the situation will
deteriorate what we're more concerned
about with China is that there will be
an emergence of a new variant because
the number of cases in China is
astronomically high but it's a new
sub-variant that has doctors concerned
here in Canada
xbb.1.5 is the latest spin-off of
Omicron it's the most transmissible
covet strain yet but its severity is
still unknown the early indications with
this new variant is that it seems to be
about the same severity as the last few
variants uh which is still far more
severe than our influenza but not as
severe as the original BC is now
reporting 12 cases of xbb.1.5 and Sophie
experts are saying that it's only a
matter of time until every Province
reports cases of the new sub-variant
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa McKenzie thank
you well new covid-19 concerns are just
one part of an overwhelming season of
respiratory illness that's putting
pressure on Canadian hospitals and
adding to that stress is an ongoing
shortage of cold and flu medication
early on the surge in sickness prompted
a run on medicine meant for Canadian
children now there's a dearth in adult
medication as well leaving more patients
and health professionals desperate for
help Daria Israel reports
one box of generic Tylenol that will
have to last this Ottawa Pharmacy until
the end of the month so as you can see
right now most of my shelf is bare owner
Matt Yang is almost out of stock of
adults cold and flu medication and he
doubts his delivery will arrive on time
the issue is we're not able to order any
more from our supply
so we have been
unfortunately turning away our customers
customers are searching endlessly I've
been in a couple times was in um two
days ago nothing the last time
I wasn't like well I came in here I was
actually just rushing in assuming I'd
find it really quickly and the shells
were completely empty they've been empty
on and off for months in the summer
parents struggled to find children's
Advil and Tylenol because of supply
chain issues a rise in respiratory
illnesses and a spike in demand that's
usually a time where manufacturers kind
of stock up or build up their reserves
to get ready for the fall
um and unfortunately because of that
kind of heightened level of activity
some of those medications have gone a
little bit short across the country and
that's had a spillover effect into now
adults Health Canada says it's
monitoring the situation closely and is
having discussions with manufacturers
but doctors Pharmacists and patients are
frustrated this keeps happening over and
over again this medication voltage has
been going on for many years it's been
lost going on for over a decade now that
it's affecting some of the most commonly
used medications health professionals
believe it's harder to ignore to
alleviate the short
Ottawa imported a million bottles of
children's cold and flu medicine last
November but with 90 percent of drugs
coming from abroad doctors warn it does
not address the supply problem either we
have the ability to manufacture them
here or we must be able to stockpile
them so for example Australians are as a
law that says that all suppliers of
drugs must stockpile six months and
without a plan the drug shortage
threatens to put more pressure on an
already overburdened Health Care System
tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
Canada's transport Minister says the
federal government is looking to make it
easier for air passengers to receive
compensation from Airlines following
flight cancellations
this is something that I am Consulting
with the transportation with
Transportation Canada on we're looking
forward to figuring out what other
measures can we put in our passenger
Bill of Rights to make sure that the
airlines are the ones who are
responsible for these claims
the comments come after Omar algabra
spoke with the CEO of sun wing Airlines
who assured him passengers would be
compensated for last month's widespread
cancellations that left hundreds of
Canadians stranded over the holidays the
airline also issued a public apology
today in which it admitted to clear
failures in responding to the weather
related delays
chaos has erupted in the Mexican state
of Sinaloa following the arrest of
cartel leader ovidio Guzman El Chapo's
son
[Music]
buses are burning around the city of
culiacan about two hours north of
Mazatlan the arum and Aeromexico plane
scheduled to fly to Mexico City this
morning was hit by gunfire on the tarmac
but no injuries have been reported that
airport and the Mazatlan airport are now
closed the federal government is
advising Canadians in the area to
shelter in place
the political circus underway in the U.S
has dragged into its third day now with
lawmakers appearing no closer to
electing a house Speaker Republicans
still can't even agree on a nominee
party leader Kevin McCarthy has offered
new concessions but a small group of
hard-line Republicans is standing in his
way and that has created a humiliating
deadlock with major impacts on
government operations Jackson prosco is
following the developing details Jackson
where do we stand with things now
well Sophie we haven't seen this level
of dysfunction in a speaker's race since
before the American Civil War and what
is so remarkable as this all unfolds is
that Kevin McCarthy keeps making major
concessions to his opponents and getting
nothing in return all day long he lost
vote after vote after vote by the same
margin tonight there are rumors of a
partial deal in the works behind the
scenes but so far no one has moved in
their positions the path forward is
completely unclear and big picture of
course in the long term there are
questions about damage being done here
to the Republican party's reputation
with many Americans watching the circus
and wondering if anyone is going to be
able to control this Congress and if
Republicans are going to be able to do
anything with their Newfound majority
it's going to make it more difficult for
them to accomplish anything and they
were already having the the deck stacked
against them because the Democratic
Senate and the Democratic White House
would probably stymie anything they were
pushing but it's it's been a spectacle
and a disaster for the Republicans
well Jackson without a speaker can
government function
essentially no this is an important
procedural Milestone and until a speaker
is elected no member of Congress can
actually officially be sworn in and
actually start doing their jobs that
means right now they can't serve their
constituents they can't have meetings or
receive classified briefings and they
can't conduct the basic business of
government now they've only lost a few
days work so far but if this drags on
much longer it could have serious
consequences as one analyst put it to me
today thank goodness there isn't a
national emergency or War underway right
now that would require the intervention
of the house Sophie absolutely all right
thanks for that Jackson prosco in
Washington Cincinnati doctors say
Buffalo Bill safety Demar Hamlin has
made substantial Improvement since his
Cardiac Arrest Monday on the football
field the 24 year old is on a ventilator
but is still awake and his neurological
function is intact doctors say Hamlin's
age Fitness and the immediate Medical
Response help prevent any identifiable
brain damage
first question that he wrote when he
when he started to awaken was it was did
we went so we know that he's really it's
not only that the lights are on we know
that he's home uh and that it appears
that all all the cylinders are firing uh
when it's in his brain which is greatly
gratifying
the game against the Cincinnati Bengals
was suspended and there are reports it
won't resume tests are ongoing to
determine the cause of Hamlin's Cardiac
Arrest the Buffalo Bills return to
practice today for the first time since
his collapse
and actor Jeremy Renner has posted this
video from his hospital bed in Reno
Nevada he says his mom and sister made a
not so great ICU day into a great spa
day thanks to that head massage and
shampoo under the shower cap Renner was
run over by his own snow cat on New
Year's Day the 51 year old is recovering
from blunt chest trauma and Orthopedic
injuries
of final farewell at the Vatican coming
up the unprecedented Funeral for a
former Pope
foreign
funeral held today at the Vatican with
the current Pope Francis presiding over
the ceremony for his predecessor
Benedict who died on New Year's Eve
[Applause]
attendees there already calling out in
it was a simple ceremony but not without
pageantry he has now been buried in the
grottos beneath Saint Peter's Basilica
in the same tomb where Pope John Paul II
lay before becoming a saint and having
his coffin moved as Redmond Shannon
reports this funeral puts the future of
the Roman Catholic Church in the
spotlight
beneath the chilly Vatican Mist a Papal
funeral like none other in modern times
[Music]
marking the life of a former Pope
Benedict XVI who stepped down from the
role almost a decade ago a smaller crowd
than four previous papal deaths is
somewhat mixed Legacy inspiring respect
among the flock more than it does
adoration unlike the death of a sitting
Pope this was not a state funeral but it
still attracted dignitaries and leaders
from traditionally Catholic countries
the main difference from every other
people's funeral for the last six
centuries
the presence of a current pontiff the
now frail Pope Francis presiding over
the service
gracious father we commend your mercy
Pope Emeritus Benedict a Fearless
preacher of your word
86 year old Francis has said that he may
one day follow Benedict and retire if
his health fails
Benedict's decision to step aside in
2013 likely informed by the long reign
of his predecessor John Paul II in his
latter years and particularly towards
his death he was clearly a very very
frail man who'd lost his ability to lead
with the precedent set the Dynamics of
Vatican succession may now have changed
forever that is the College of cardinals
who elect the next Pope but I'm sure
there's all sorts of jostling for
position going on and a lot hangs on it
because Pope Francis has been making
appointments of cardinals who are more
likely to continue his vision of the
church Theologian Tina Beatty says part
of that vision is the ongoing
consultation process with Catholics
worldwide to shape the future direction
of the church something Francis will
want to lead over the coming two years
whatever the future of Francis the
Catholic church does not change fast
the ancient traditions on display at
Benedict's burial in the Crypt of Saint
Peter's Basilica is a testament to that
Redmond Shannon Global News London
changing child welfare ahead the cause
to fix a failing system after the tragic
death of an indigenous child
[Music]
the apprehension and treatment of
indigenous children by child welfare
systems across the country is under the
microscope in a scathing report out of
Alberta this week a judge has released
new recommendations after an inquiry
into the death of a four-year-old girl
Serenity died eight years ago while in
the care of relatives but as Heather
urich's West reports the judge says the
child's death can be traced back to the
date she was taken from her mother
her story is difficult to hear
four-year-old Serenity emaciated and
covered in bruises died of head trauma
in 2014. she had been living with
relatives eight years later an Alberta
judge has found the events leading to
her death began the day she was removed
from her mother's care
she said for a long time
there was a lot of wrongdoing Serenity's
Guardians were charged with failing to
provide the necessaries of life though
not in connection to her death those
charges were eventually stayed in a
report released Wednesday Justice Renee
Coulter made nearly two dozen
recommendations on how to prevent
similar tragedies focusing first on a
child's apprehension itself
the first priority of children's
services is to ensure that indigenous
mothers especially young indigenous
mothers receive the support they need to
raise their children in a healthy
environment she said while indigenous
children make up less than eight percent
of Canada's overall child population
they represent more than half of the
kids in foster care Canada's child
welfare systems are often called the
residential schools of present day we
need to tear this whole system down
that's what needs to happen there is no
fixing the system because Children's
Services is not a broken system
Children's Services is a system that is
working exactly the way it was intended
to work it's why many First Nations and
metis settlements are now working
towards taking over as child welfare
services providers for their communities
this is the beginning of the end of the
child welfare system as we know it I see
the First Nations formulating their own
law and which will have a huge impact on
indigenous children and metis children
and I think will be a better step one
that will hopefully lead to significant
change with fewer indigenous children
ending up in provincial care Heather
York's West Global News Calgary
Prince Harry's new book spare isn't even
on store shelves yet but it's already
making headlines with Harry's claim he
was attacked by his brother according to
the UK newspaper the guardian which saw
an advanced copy of the book Harry says
he was physically attacked by Prince
William during a heated conversation
about Harry's wife Megan he writes it
all happened so fast so very fast he
grabbed me by the caller ripping my
necklace and he knocked me to the floor
the leaked passage goes on to say
William returned remorseful and
apologized spare will officially be
released January 10. an amateur
archaeologist has helped discover the
meaning behind a primitive writing
system used by hunter-gatherers twenty
thousand years ago Ben bacon who's a
British Furniture restorer by trade
worked to decode dots and other markings
on paintings he deduced those marks were
to record The Mating cycles of animals
his research is now being published
alongside a team from Durham diversity
in the UK that's global national for
this Thursday I'm Sophie Louis tonight's
your Canada is this bird's eye view of a
neighborhood in Kimberly British
Columbia thanks for watching and hope to
see you here again tomorrow
[Music]